this video is sponsored by honey now
this is how you develop and build up an
arc
dressrosa is on track to being one of if
not my favorite arcs in the series so
far
and it's been a pretty surreal journey
over the last four months to say the
least
coming from being a complete newbie to
the series to now having covered 745
chapters in total
and on the 27th arc of the series and
i'm not even covering this entire arc in
this one video
heck i'm barely covering 40 of it
because dressrosa
is so unbelievably girthy never have i
read through an act that has offered so
much
so often it's absolutely brilliant and
chocked full of interesting information
and story
so much information in fact that i have
to tackle this monster of an arc in two
separate videos
in this one i'll be covering the events
covered in chapter 700 all the way
through to 745
with next week fully completing the arc
and let me tell you there was way more
than enough to review and talk about in
this one video alone it has more key
events than both fishman island and punk
hazard combined and has captured my
attention like no
other story that's come before it so
what are we waiting for let's kick off
my first impressions of thoughts on
and review four a story that's
impressive clever and action-packed in
equal measure
i'm totally not mark and this is
dressrosa
now before i dive headfirst into
dressrosa there were a few things i want
to talk about real quick that i didn't
have time
to or simply forgot to cover in last
week's video so let's start with
something i didn't really have much to
say about in the first place but totally
understand why it's there and why it's
important and that's the sea plot of
punk hazard
the rescue of momonosuke personally i
enjoyed how this was handled but didn't
really have much to say about it
in my punk hazard video i mentioned that
the entire motivation for kinemon in
that arc was to rescue his son
and during the third act of the story
when luffy gets trapped in a trash heap
we find momonosuke having eaten a devil
fruit that transformed him into
a traditional chinese dragon again this
looks like one of the fake devil fruits
that were developed by
caesar at the time he doesn't really
play that much of a role in this arc but
but it does strike me as something that
will become much more important later on
specifically
with regards to the fake devil fruit
that he's eaten and the implications of
that said item
next up zora and tashigi vs monet during
the final effort to reach caesar in punk
hazards zorro found himself needing to
stop monet and eventually toshigi with
the g5 troops supporting the effort
what's interesting about this isn't
necessarily the choreography for me or
the action but the character of zorro in
and of itself
in this altercation with monet despite
her posing a real threat to
everyone zoro refuses to take her out
effectively simply because
she's a woman and what's interesting
about this specific scene is that
kashigi someone who reminds zoro of his
childhood rival
takes specific issue with that now the
specific struggle his old childhood
rival had was overcoming expectations
from society
to become a warrior and i don't think
zoro fully understands that yet and this
scene was a direct indication of that
what he chose to do in not taking out
monet in this instance is quite
obviously a mistake on zorro's part in
the story and had caesar not at the
perfect time stabbed her in the heart
unknowingly
zoro would have been single-handedly
responsible for the deaths of
hundreds and his crew as monet blew
herself and the facility up
in caesar's name this for me indicated
that this will eventually be
zorro's arc to come to respect the
ability of a warrior regardless of their
gender
to empathize with and understand his
childhood rival finally and to see
toshigi as a warrior and not
as a woman when they battle and that
brings us to what i wanted to talk about
this week
what the ending of punk hazard means and
dressrosa
personally i thought how the last arc
ended offered this upcoming dressroche
arc a much needed alley oop when it came
to stakes tension and plot
at the end of punk hazard it introduced
us to the lesser subordinates of
doflamingo in baby five and buffalo as
they are tasked with retrieving caesar
right before the end of that arc
however they fail and in doing so we do
find that they sealed the fate of their
master
leaving law to give him an ultimatum
either he kills caesar and doflamingo
would have to face the wrath of kaido
as he could no longer supply him with
what he needs or more favorably
he must quit the seven warlords of the
sea and renounce his position as king of
dressrosa
needless to say he chooses the option
that doesn't have him dancing with an
emperor of the sea
and thus are the circumstances leading
into dressrosa law
along with the straw hats and caesar
make their way to the island to drop him
off as part
of their bargain but one other curious
interaction occurred that i'm guessing
has a big implication for the future
at the very end of this punk hazard arc
with the straw hats having gone and
doflamingo having arrived on the island
smoker is left to take the wrath of don
but
moments before he loses his life aokiji
stops him
right in his tracks protecting someone
that he refers to as
an old friend before later suggesting
that the greatest challenge yet faced
is on the horizon then disappearing once
again
now if that doesn't make you curious as
to what's to come i don't know what will
and with that the straw hats have
finally arrived at dressrosa
and so we are finally on the island and
i freaking
love this arc and the direction it's
heading personally but moreover i am
utterly floored by the staggering amount
of
information detail and depth this arc
adds to the overall one-piece world
while feeling way lighter than it has
any right to be while also introducing
what feels like hundreds of new
characters but to be fair most of these
are no names from the bouts of the
coliseum later in the story and yeah
you heard me right this arc has coliseum
battles to the death it's also got
living toys and it's got a blind guy
that might be one of the coolest
characters introduced yet
and the funny thing about all this is
everything i just said here doesn't even
begin to scratch the surface of what
dressrosa has to offer
one thing that this arc did that i
haven't seen any other act do better
except for perhaps marineford
is make me care about how the events
that unfold go down and i'm not
exaggerating here it only builds
throughout this arcs runtime
arriving at a point during chapter 745
that has me
primed to read more once i get done
recording this video i mean i'm serious
i'm picking it right up after this and
personally i think that's a really
important thing to be feeling at this
point in the story
when your arc is as long as dresrosa is
there are two things you need to make
sure are taken care of and that's pacing
and how interesting it is
it's tricky to balance but dressrosa
does this better than any other axe so
far in my opinion keeping things
interesting by interweaving
existing and newly established plot
threads together in very compelling ways
and it keeps the pace feeling snappy by
revealing new pieces of vital
information
crucial new characters and swerves that
keep us on the edge of our seats and
unbalanced as we try to figure out just
what the hell is happening on this
island from the very beginning of this
arc in addition to the setup and goals
established in punk hazard
something i criticized in the last video
seems to have been rectified in
dresarosa and that's
panelling though still not at its best a
large section of this portion of
dressrosa is paneled well and clear
easily communicating how the characters
are feeling as well as the wildlife
architecture cultures
and notable structures visible on the
curious island
of dressrosa but before ever landing on
the island the crew and law establish
and break down the plan of action before
diving into their respective squads the
first squad is to deliver caesar the
second squad is to take care of and
watch over the sunny
and finally the third team is to destroy
the factory that produces the artificial
devil fruits
three separate teams with three very
different goals and right from the
get-go this made for some really great
pacing as each scene offered something
new and fresh compared to the other
however
something curious regarding this section
that i found particularly noteworthy was
luffy's exclusion from the squad that
drops off caesar and his placement
alongside sanji frankie and zoro
in the factory demolition squad and
while rob and usop went with law to
deliver caesar
the fact that luffy zorro and sanji
weren't assigned to that particular
section
told me something and it was confirmed
later
and i will talk about that later but
right now there are three groups
established right away all with
different missions and what made this
work
so well for me was that the conflicts
each team encounters
made the story infinitely more engaging
and exciting whether it be through the
sunny's abrupt and artistic overtaking
the treacherous route taken to greenbit
island to drop off caesar or the very
curious scene shared by luffy and the
older blind man as they stopped to eat
on route to the factory
in dressrosa and speaking of that last
one i found it to be awesome
simple and perhaps telling of what's to
come in the future
having decided to stop to grab some food
and drink luffy zorro sanji kinemon
and frankie all sit down in an
establishment as they overhear the older
blind men
being taken advantage of by some thugs
and with luffy being luffy he walks up
to them and makes sure that they play
fair
resulting in the blind man making all of
his money back and giving his thanks to
luffy but
just as suddenly as he came into their
lives a massive hole opens up on the
floor of the cafe
swallowing up anyone that were to have
fallen into it as the old man makes his
way to the door
luffy remarks at how strong he is asking
who he was
in response to this he turns to face
luffy and suggests that keeping that to
himself might be better for the both of
them
okay so immediately i'm hooked but
what's more is that due to that
important key event
zoro notices that he is now without any
of his swords they've been stolen
zoro then concludes that the old man
must have taken them despite everyone
around them seemingly concluding that it
must have been
fairies or something okay
and so this leads to that particular
group tasked with destroying the factory
to fraction into a bunch of different
ones and with this next scene
i knew i was in store for something
really really fun
and impressive when usopp robin law and
caesar arrive on green bit while
exploring the jungle of the area
for navy soldiers both robin and usop
get taken underground
by these tiny people all the while law
is met with two interesting individuals
for the exchange
doflamingo and that old blind man
going by the name of fujitora he is a
new admiral in the navy
my jaw in this moment hit the floor and
as my jaw is on this floor
it's also explained in robin and usop's
situation down underground with these
tiny little things that the fairies the
towns people were speaking of
actually did steal zorro's sword and
that is what i meant about two seemingly
unrelated plot threads becoming tangled
creating tension and excitement much
more than what they would have been able
to do on their own
and there's more this scene keeps on
giving on top of fujitora an admiral of
the navy now facing law
on top of doflamingo now facing law on
top of
fairies actually existing and stealing
zorro's swords
doflamingo reveals that he's lied he is
still
part of the seven warlords and he is
still the king of dressrosa
which means this admiral dude that we
see before us right now that can
summon meteors needs to be contended
with along with doflamingo
so okay two of the straw hats have been
taken captive law is left alone in a
standoff against doflamingo and fujitora
who can create
meteors and the other straw hats are
scattered across dressrosa doing god
knows what and this isn't even the good
part yet
this is the setup so let me talk about
one of my favorite aspects of the story
and that is the colosseum speaking
somewhat generally this arc is unique as
it's the only one that has ever created
mysteries simply by using its
inhabitants in an effective way dotted
all across the island are living toys
that can talk and move on their own
no one seems to know why or how these
little guys came to be here but
at the end of every day they need to
return to a certain place on the island
and the cornerstone of this mystery
comes in the form of a character i will
call hen's fourth toy soldier with zorro
having gone looking for his swords and
sanji having become
a little preoccupied with the dancing
girl called viola both luffy and frankie
stumble across this little guy
outside of an event held in the coliseum
of dressrosa
by the king a free to enter tournament
with the winning prize being the flame
flame devil fruit containing powers once
held by luffy's brother
fire fist ace this blew my mind and my
excitement suddenly shot up from an
eight to 100 degrees celsius man the
flame flame fruit is by far and away my
favorite devil fruit
and my favorite powers in general not
only am i massively invested in luffy
and someone on her side to get these
epic firepowers
but i am also an enormous fan of
tournament arcs in general if done well
they offer a really interesting but easy
to understand vehicle for great story to
be told and it offers far more
characters the chance to establish
themselves that otherwise might be
impossible to do
under different circumstances and while
this tournament sort of sits on its own
to the side of everything
eventually like everything else in this
arc it all ties together in an
impressive and
elegant way so let's dig into this
tournament what did i think of it
well speaking as a dragon ball fan a
series that is made up of tons and tons
of different tournament arcs
i loved this addition to one piece of
story and while reading
it hit me that oda managed to make it
700 chapters
in a manga before diving into a torment
arc
with luffy now that's rather unique
given the genre at hand but
regardless i thought this tournament
served the story being told
perfectly we have a terrific goal to
shoot for in the flame flame fruit and
we have tons of great matchups to look
forward to as well and speaking of
dragon ball
something i really appreciated while
reading through this was luffy's choice
of disguise
you see in the first tournament of
dragon ball master roshi enters in
disguise to make sure goku doesn't win
but in this tournament luffy dresses up
like master roshi which i thought was
hilarious upon first viewing regardless
it's here luffy becomes acquainted with
the facility sporting a massive statue
of its supposed finest gladiator with
3 000 victories and zero losses though
the legitimacy of this particular person
having ever existed seems to have been
lost at time
in addition to that we learned that the
first rounds of the tournament to see
four separate free-for-all battles each
with over a hundred people participating
the four winners from that will then
move into the next and final round and
what makes this entertaining
is the hijinks and effort luffy has to
go to in order to protect his identity
from being revealed
meeting terrible individuals like jesus
burj is from blackbeard's crew
sent there to retrieve the ability in
order to bolster his forces
and somewhat similarly everyone else was
introduced in this section
wants the fruit to further their own
selfish desires like cavendish who was
once the most popular pirate before
luffy came along and now resents him
there's xinjiao and his family who have
a long-standing beef with the monkey
name but of course there's also those
with altruistic goals and none better
embody that in this tournament than the
character of rebecca
an undefeated gladiator who's as kind as
her outfit is
ridiculous and with these different
interactions with these new characters
as well as old ones like bellamy who's
back by the way
and sporting a totally different outlook
on life full of respect for luffy it
serves as a fantastic way to manage a
manga's pacing there's some great
comedies some touching moments and some
revealing instances like luffy's
collision with xinjiao someone garp
cross
many years back and he still holds a
grudge against luffy and his family and
heading into his first battle royal with
blackbeard's flunky and the crazy
man-eating loon called bartelomeo having
already qualified
luffy is next up to topple all of those
in his group including xinjiao something
that i also really liked about this
section
specifically that's on display is its
paneling there's some superb action
shots with some great imagery using
luffy's small body to heavily contrast
all the massive opponents
he's standing against and this battle is
pretty awesome there's a fighter from
elbaf that towers over all the
competition but one that stands out
beyond
all others is qin zhao when he begins
using the same hockey power
that luffy specializes in the power of
the supreme king i really enjoyed chen's
design here it's understated and
frankly really awesome when he channels
his haki ability and with
one punch everyone in the arena is sent
flying out of bounds as the two titans
clash their tremendous fists together
there's an awesome sense of impact and
occasion during this clash and the
panels capture that perfectly but to cut
a long story short he resents luffy
because garp destroyed the shape of his
head preventing him from unlocking his
treasure somewhere underneath the ground
it's the sins of the father or
grandfather in this instance type of
thing
but luffy has this great line in
response to his complaining
he says one punch who cares he's punched
me
countless times and then proceeds to
punch him with a massive fist that gives
him back the shape of his head
winning the battle royal i'm still not
sure what if any significance xinjiang
plays in the greater arc or greater
story as a whole but maybe it was only a
chance occurrence and that's going to be
the end of him here and now but that
doesn't really sound like one piece to
me really so i wouldn't be surprised if
he does pick up again somewhere
regardless that's him pretty much done
for the rest of this video's material at
least and with luffy now qualified
we're greeted with another interesting
encounter and this coliseum plot line
for luffy will be more invested in the
flame flame through coming into luffy's
possession
we're also exposed to dozens of new
characters and this is honestly rich for
comedic moments
like this bartolomeo guy i touched on
earlier introduced as this
vicious savage of a human being said to
have even eaten people when he speaks
about luffy and his exploits it's
revealed that he's actually a crazed
superfan having been there in low town
the day luffy declared that he wants to
be the pirate king
while on the chopping blocks he sort of
becomes a vital tool later in the story
but essentially he's a crazed superfan
and that's just really funny and little
things like that
as we meet characters that are not
important and others very important
lead to some really fun moments in the
story like this one with rebecca
congratulating luffy on his win
and her round still to come in block d
she gives luffy food before luring him
down in the cell blocks to be ambushed
all in an effort to squash the
competition and give herself a better
chance at winning but
[Music]
it's here we begin to see and understand
how deep the turmoil within dressrosa
goes
and we start to get this impression that
all is not well in this strange place
during rebecca's flashback and this is
one of many flashbacks
oda uses to tremendous effect in this
arc each one after the other
recontextualizing what we've already
seen
adding further detail and history to
this already vibrant
and alive world he's created which is
exactly what a great flashback scene
should do
and we get a bunch of these great
flashback sequences in this story that
ultimately culminate in a fantastic
swerve that i honestly didn't see coming
even in the slightest but
i'll get to that a little bit later
during this particular flashback we are
made aware of rebecca's tragic past how
she remembers her mother fondly how they
struggled for food and how one day
after she left to go get some food for
her she returned to them in the arms of
a toy soldier
dead it's sad to say the least and it's
here we begin to understand the
significance of this little one-legged
soldier and it's also obvious to discern
through this flashback
why rebecca is the way that she is she
was cared for and trained intensely by
the toy soldier and now can defend
herself
she knows that there's something wrong
and she wants to win the devil fruit to
bring about order and peace in her
country
and these are more than reasonable goals
we find as she also is the wielder of a
particular type of haki
in this instance she can dodge and
predict her opponent's movements like no
other
effectively eliminating people using
their own momentum against them so she's
not really a slouch either
although her outfit is one of the most
ridiculous things i've ever seen in my
entire life and all the while this is
taking place during the tournament
frankie has been in the company of this
toy soldier whom we now understand as
someone that looks over and protects her
explaining why he was there in the first
place and it's that sort of attention to
detail that i adore
but don't get comfortable here because
this is only just getting started and
from this point on the story kicks
itself into
overdrive like seriously this arc is
nuts for getting stuff done
and exposing new interesting plot
threads as of right now frankie is with
the toy soldier heading for the
rendezvous point sanji has been led
astray and then
changed a woman named biola for the
better who also is guiding him in
another direction
zoro has managed to track down the
little person who stole his sword and he
too is being filled in on what's going
on
it seems like all of this is connected
and it totally is
which was a great feeling to get while
reading through it and if that wasn't
enough
while this is all happening law is being
destroyed by the combined forces of
fujitora
who can create meteors and doflamingo
and that's not even to make mention of
the situation back in the sunny it's one
terrible thing after another befalling
our heroes in the story which on its own
serves to build up a lot of tension but
moreover the contrast in all of these
different circumstances helps us retain
interest in the story without getting
winded from over exposure to a
particular setting there's a lot of
variety here with one scene being water
another being open beach more in the
city and one in a coliseum
every scene offers something narratively
and visually different which
is a welcome change from punk hazard or
fishman island in the last few weeks but
back to the story at hand you see a plan
of some description has been spoken of
whenever these little fairy characters
called totanas
are on screen once again the concept of
this plan
being made today sounds somewhat
circumstantial with it being the day the
straw hats arrive at all until you
realize that they chose to do this there
and then
because they too were under the
impression that doflamingo had quit the
seven warlords
everything in this story makes sense so
far and ties together in such a natural
way
it hurts every piece of information
slowly forms a greater picture
adding a new angle or means with which
to view the narrative from giving
greater appreciation to these little
guys's plight as well as the hard
circumstances now after befalling the
sunny and the team of nami brook and
chopper
left to guard it you see and this is why
i love doflamingo doflamingo was one
step ahead of literally
everyone from the get-go he never quit
the warlords he staged the entire
article in the papers he planted the
devil fruit as a prize in the colosseum
because he wanted luffy to be lured
there to be captured and he has set his
people
to take care of the ship and take care
of them they do gyola now one of the
members of the don quixote family
stands between the straw hats and their
beloved ship having used her devil fruit
ability the likes of which we haven't
seen in quite some time changing them
all into different works of art
all of them in different styles nami is
sort of picasso i think but the best one
of all is brooke who's mimicking edvard
munch
the scream and now with the sunny having
been turned into a piece of artwork in
and of itself
and with the crew having no way of
defending themselves it seems as though
things couldn't get
any worse and that's when law makes a
distress call to the sunny ordering them
to swing by green bit
to pick them up so not ideal
circumstances right now but
through some clever misdirection by
brooke the crew managed to regain
control of the ship and dispose of
guiola
the first move that hasn't gone
according to the doflamingo
plan
i'd like to thank honey for sponsoring
today's video more and more it's
starting to feel like online shopping is
the only shopping we do
and that's where today's sponsor comes
in honey it's completely free and if you
don't know what it is
let me tell you that you should have
this on your computer it's a completely
free browser extension that scours the
internet for promo codes and
automatically tests them when you're
about to buy something like
this thing literally tries to save you
money and it's free it seems like a
no-brainer so
you get honey on your computer for free
in like literally two clicks then when
you're checking out of one of its 30 000
supported sites
honey pops up and all you have to do is
click apply coupon if honey finds
working codes
it'll apply the best one for your cart i
mean look check out these savings like
five dollars on a pizza honey has found
it's over 17 million members
over two billion dollars in savings and
if you want to be one of them
simply click on the link in the
description or search
jointhoney.com tnm simply put if you
want to save money and support this
channel get honey for free today by
going to joinhoney.com
tnm that's joinhoney.com tnm
so they know i sent you hey you don't
have to leave any for me
they're all yours i'll just watch
additionally now that we are getting a
better idea of the true scope of this
conflict
we recognize the sudden capture of robin
and usop into the undergrounds of
greenberg thanks to the ton tatas which
was also not part of doflamingo's plan
down there usopp and robin learn of the
little guy's struggles and how their
people have been through a ton with the
various rulers
together they wish to launch a revolt
against the don quixote family with the
added help of the toy soldier
and while this is a b plot it's by all
means just as crucial as the other
moving parts of the story for me helping
alleviate a lot of the tension and
stress with much needed comedic value
through scenes like usopp lying to them
pretending to be a relative of noland
who is a hero to these little guys too
by the way which
on its own is super interesting and this
isn't the only time the events of skype
are brought up either back at the
coliseum earlier in the story bellamy
made everyone aware that he had been to
the sky island as well
and caused all sorts of trouble for the
inhabitants both of those events are
curious but
more so the noland one as he up until
this point
wasn't brought up in any context outside
of skype yet i guess he must have
approached it from that direction than
if he did in fact go there but as the
tontat has worshipped us up and robin
for their offered help
suddenly the entire island starts to
shake it's the titanic battle that's
taking place outside between la fujitora
and dolflamingo and this battle is
really interesting as while i was
reading through it
there were subtle hints dotted
throughout that there was more going on
than i once thought like
law intentionally not using any of his
energy to help the effort
in getting to green bit in the first
place citing that he's saving it
for doflamingo knowing full well that he
intended on duking it out with him in
the first place
but i don't think he counted on things
going so wrong so fast either
however thankfully the ship arrives to
scoop them away despite law insisting on
staying behind to try his best at
defeating him
but they can't get away looming above
them masterfully utilizing his ability
spies doflamingo above the sunny redding
a massive strike when suddenly
this was amazing sanji has some of the
best subversive saves in the entire
series like i left out of my seat when
this happened and
man did i love it and not because sanji
could stand up to doflamingo
more specifically because he couldn't
and he tried anyway
i love these moments from a character
perspective especially for sanji and
this was a peak moment for him too i
think
thanks to some clever planning and some
perfectly timed teamwork they managed to
get away from doflamingo for a moment
with caesar
but not with law
okay slow down what the heck is
happening here
this arc is bloody insane with the
amount of things that are happening and
how often things progress in this
it's a long story admittedly but it's by
no means boring
it's one of the most consistently
interesting stories i've been exposed to
so far in one piece
like luffy zorro and are gathered
towards the edge of the colosseum with
zorro giving luffy lift for not telling
him about the tournament in the first
place
when suddenly boom down comes doflamingo
with law as if to prove a point
and doflamingo shoots law with a gun now
where have i seen that kind of behavior
before and to make matters worse
zorro lunges in to help but is stopped
in his tracks by the new admiral
fujitora
and luffy can't help because get this
the bars of the colosseum are sea prism
the coliseum is clearly built to hold
people inside and if you thought things
couldn't get any worse
they friggin do rigging through on a
snail is the team back safely on the
sunny only
they're not safe they're being pursued
by
big mom this was the single best
sequence of events i've ever
experienced in one piece the suspense
the not knowing the action the
excitement and the reveals
it doesn't stop to catch its breath for
even a split second
and i freaking adore this it's exactly
what i want from an adventure story like
this and it's something that only could
be possible
with a story as deep and fleshed out as
one piece there are so many
possibilities that oftentimes
it's practically impossible to figure
out what comes next
and needless to say the big mom chase i
did not expect even in the slightest
though her presence absolutely in this
instance makes sense
now completely separate with everything
having gone wrong
law having been dragged back to the
palace along with doflamingo and
fujitora
luffy trapped inside the coliseum and
the revolution going down on this very
day with nothing in place from the straw
hats
this is exactly the sort of manic energy
i should be
feeling right now all the plot lines are
after converging in one form or another
and
splashed out in all sorts of different
chaotic directions
leaving the heroes at a massive
disadvantage it's spectacular to read
through and it's at this point in the
story i should mention that my reading
experience during this arc has been
significantly better than that which
i've experienced since the time skip
not to say that anything i've read
through was bad or anything but
this clearly is at a completely
different standard in terms of pacing
every chapter it feels like a greater
amount of progression has taken place
and or something vitally important
happens with chapter 730 being a
prime example of that and i think it
achieves this specifically because of
punk hazard in this instance as well as
fishman island in the case for big mom
doing all the heavy lifting in terms of
setup but that's not to say that
dressrosa doesn't set up anything on its
own either
because it absolutely does and you might
think that at this point there isn't
much
video left to discuss with there just
being 15 chapters or so left to cover
but holy hell would you be wrong for
thinking that and it's in this section
of the story i made aware of the level
of patience this arc has in implementing
its story having covered the events of
the coliseum and acquainted
us with the building we learned that
those that lose are transported to the
factory beneath the building
and turned into toys by this little girl
called sugar
and let me tell you this little girl
freaks me out more than any other
entity in the one piece story or maybe
even fiction
her powers are utterly terrifying and
there's no telling how old she is either
as these powers sort of freeze her age
in time apparently
so okay get this all the toys throughout
this island are her
own creation they were once people but
that's not even the terrifying part
the scary part is that once she changes
you into a toy
everyone and i mean literally everyone
on planet earth
forgets that you ever existed but you
yourself as a toy still remember
everything bound by a contract that
sugar utters after your creation
you must obey the gun kihoto family and
you cannot harm
people now what's interesting about that
specifically is while reading this i
recall that in rebecca's flashback the
toy soldier could hurt humans
specifically made aware of this fact
during her own training sequence
teaching her how to defend herself
and this is hugely significant as all
the other toys seem to be bound by this
one rule
and this is when we finally get a
glimpse into the true life of the toy
soldier and
before getting into it without reading
it yourself i don't think this flashback
can be nearly as effective
going by the name of kiros having grown
up a down and out thug on the streets
with
tremendous fighting potential he was
eventually taken into the coliseum to
fight
there he easily racked up 100 fights won
with
zero losses in record time and as the
fights rolled on by in only a matter of
nine years he accumulated 3
000 consecutive victories eventually
gaining a new respect for himself and
ultimately became the leader of the
royal family's guard
this is where we see viola king riku and
scarlet rebecca's mother and it's in
this flashback that we learned that he
was not only rebecca's father but he was
the statue that stands in the coliseum
grounds
they had all simply forgotten about the
man behind the statue
and you know it's a tale as old as time
scarlett and he fall in love they run
off together have a child
but all is not well in the kingdom
doflamingo seems to have caused a
tremendous amount of chaos and once
chris
goes to investigate he's captured and
shackled by his leg
but as soon as king riku's life is put
in danger kiro slices off his own leg
and
lunges at doflamingo to cleave off his
head however
in doing so sugar manages to touch him
before he can make contact
transforming the one's immense gladiator
into a small toy soldier he escapes with
the king but the damage is done
neither the king nor his wife or even
his kid
recognize him or remember him i loved
this flashback and for me
it was one of the highlights of this
entire arc creating this amazingly
sympathetic character in rebecca riku
and kiros culminating in a moment that
makes me cast my mind back to the start
of the arc where i learned about the
statue
in the first place and this statue is
mentioned on more than one or two
occasions during the story too but i
never copted or made the connection
until this flashback
illuminated all the mystery and
admittedly at this moment things aren't
looking great for the protagonists of
the story they are either being pursued
captured or trapped with law himself
being on the verge of death thanks to
doflamingo and fujitora
all now having headed back to the palace
oh wait i forgot to mention something
it's a little important nothing too
major
domingo is a celestial dragon the lore
in this story
is ridiculous so now that i've learned
about the 20 kings who all but one
family gathered together to form the
world government i now know that
alabasta
and the kingdom down there will play a
massive role in the future i foresee
that the celestial dragons are those
with the royal blood
are capable perhaps of something or
needed for something significant
and vivi in alabasta will eventually
play a large role in the story once
again
i have no idea what that might be as of
yet but i'm certain it will rear its
head eventually
one doesn't simply just leave a
chekhov's gun there with no reason
behind it
there's just a crazy amount of stuff
being covered in this arc guys so
the group being chased by big mom are
fleeing to the island of zou thank god
now i can focus my attention on the
events of dressrosa where luffy wants to
chase after doflamingo but is trapped in
the coliseum
and then this happens
okay so i have this mystery person to
look forward to now
and judging from the expression on
luffy's face and the last panel of that
revealed chapter
i think i know who this is but to be
honest moreover from this
i am just in love with the world
building on display in this arc between
the tantanas who i've barely touched on
in but will in a sec
the toy civilization and secret society
the criminal
underworld exposed to doflamingo as well
as the sheer amount of information
gathered about the past
is utterly insane to say that i am
buzzing to see what comes next
is an understatement and then let's just
dive into the revolution now that
kinemon luffy and zoro are
all making moves towards the palace to
fight doflamingo and the tentative
forces are making their move into the
factory to take out sugar and to free
all the toys from her curse
in doing so it will throw the country
into disarray and they will finally
hopefully come to their senses about
doflamingo and the lies he spawned to
get to where he is today
additionally something of note here also
is that doflamingo is a terrific
villain if that isn't abundantly clear
already and he might be my favorite
after crocodile and the ark isn't even
over yet so there's still a good chance
for him to actually edge it over him he
has his own distinct identity the powers
are fierce yet unpredictable and the
backstory he shares concerning the past
as well as his overtaking of dressrosa
is both ruthless and calculated
in equal measure serving this arc
immensely had this been a lesser villain
the entire arc would have suffered
greatly i believe
and that's not even to make mention of
this new character lighting up the
finals of the tournament in luffy's
place
but this over here specifically in
particular is my favorite section of the
tantata subplot concerning usopp
robin and the little guys as their
attempt to knock out sugar and
ultimately free everyone from their
lives as toys and restore the memories
of the country
and probably the world and it's here in
this section of the story i believe we
get a glimpse at the scope of sugar's
powers
and what they might mean for the future
of this series the idea that this person
can effectively create a slave out of
someone while erasing their impression
on the world
is incredibly unsettling and powerful
and this scene
is filled with circumstances and
scenarios that i found both rich with
character
and just flat out fascinating the first
coming from robin who when she notices
that treble one of the key members in
the don quixote family
looming over sugar as a bodyguard
protecting her from pretty much anything
even coming remotely close to her
and that's when robin comes up with the
ingenious move of pretending to be a
worker there informing them of a
conflict at the dock that requires
treble's attention and
i just love how smooth she is in this
interaction but the best part comes when
treble realizes that he's been duped and
sees robin running away only for that
robin that he catches up to
and pins down to be a freaking decoy
short but a great scene informed by
character however despite treble out of
the way
for now sugar proves to be far much more
than she even lets on
with her changing a large number of the
forces of the tantatas to toys along
with robin and
again all of their friends and family
immediately forget that they've lost
anything
she even eventually changes robin and
uzop forgets she exists
and this is when something super
interesting happens
when i first watched this i enjoyed the
scene that ultimately played
out but i had some reservations
regarding usop in this instance
thinking that he should have been past
this sort of behavior for the most part
but
thankfully something super interesting
was brought to my attention that
really highlights the strength of
sugar's character and the importance
that the straw hat crew mean to each
other you see
a lot of this history behind usop's
bravery and really the crux of his
bravery in general comes from
soga king it's an identity that he's
used in the past as a security blanket
like in thriller bark
but when robin was removed from the
equation not only did he suddenly find
himself in a dangerous situation without
backup but he was also after losing the
impetus for soga king he had lost all of
his development and motivations
throughout
amy's lobby which is where a lot of his
bravery and character was born now
obviously this is just conjecture but i
think it stands to reason that when
usopp lost a part of his crew in robin
from his memory he too lost a large part
of himself that made him as brave as he
was today once again it's the attention
to detail that this story
time after time after time after time
i'm blown away by with callbacks to
prior events to fantastic subversions on
the back of monumental moments
whenever oda builds to a reveal it never
feels uninteresting to me and when he
builds to an action crescendo
it always hits its mark and this time is
no different
[Applause]
with all the toys suddenly turning back
into real people
and all the folks around the island
suddenly recalling all of their lost
memories
including rebecca who for the first time
in her adult life remembers that her
father
is alive and speaking of which once zoro
begins his awesome fight with pika
luffy kiros and kinemon get very close
to the palace
without hesitation and mighty purpose
now fully back to being himself the
titanic gladiator with 3 000 consecutive
in the coliseum motivated by the loss of
his life and the loss of his greatest
love scarlet
assuming the exact same position and
attack he never got to land last time
with a massive slash he beheads the
flamingo
much to the shock of everyone in the
room having been waiting for this moment
for 10 years
finally he gets his opportunity and man
was a cathartic you can tell
this character was chomping at the bit
to get his hands on doflamingo
i mean if you beat luffy into the room
you know you're really keen
however as i said at the beginning of
this video this is only 40
of this arc and doe flamingo is far from
defeated in this instance
revealing that he's been using a
scapegoat body double doflamingo
recognizes that things
aren't going according to plan and now
that things are getting pretty messy
it's time for the birdcage and to that i
say
what the hell is that and the very fact
that i'm only 40 of my way through this
story should tell you
everything you need to know about this
tale it is without an ounce of hyperbola
one of the most densely packed and
enjoyable stories i have read so far
in this manga epic dressrosa so far has
dished out more
information than i can cover and has
offered up more material than i even
discussed in most arcs
and we aren't even halfway through what
is happening
we've been introduced to the bulk if not
all of the subordinates of dolflamingo
with my personal favorite being senior
pink who
is just the strangest most delightful
character oda has ever concocted out of
his mind but i'm sure i'll speak more
about him next week
and it's this special brand of comedic
strangeness mixed with awesome moments
like heroes offered
or heck the colosseum finals which by
the way the end of that was
chef's kiss handled again absolutely
perfectly utilizing every character in
it to the max
rebecca being the one out of her depth
and with bartolomeo and the new guy
protecting her
from blackbeard's imposing jesus burgess
with it coming down to the wire the
cloaked figure finally grabbing the
flame flame fruit and he
erupting into the sky propelled by fire
saving rebecca at the last possible
second
he is the victor and he is the returning
sabo
now part of the revolutionary army along
with koala a little girl from fisher
tiger's flashback sequence in fishman
island
this arc it's nuts standing on the
shoulders of the arks that came before
it
from this point in the story i can
really appreciate how the prior arcs
have set the tone
and set this one up and honestly i
cannot begin to predict what's still to
come
given all that has happened already and
we now have sabo back
this is amazing and honestly i just want
to get back to reading it so
i hope you guys enjoyed this video i
will be sure to talk about god who stop
next week
and thank you so much for watching
hey